>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Mao: Good morning everyone.
Well-- I feel like I
should be standing here
and singing the national anthem.
But I don't want to
scare anybody away
since we have a nice crowd here.
My name is David Mao and I
have the honor of serving
as the acting Librarian of Congress.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
It is our nation's oldest,
Federal, cultural institution.
Excuse me, I should say our first,
And we are just so
delighted that all
of you could be with us here today.
We are the Library of
Congress and we were created
by Congress 216-- almost
216 years ago.
And have been generously supported
by Congress over the years
to become the world's
largest library.
And we're very proud of that fact.
But we are the nation's library
but as our name suggests.
We are the Library for Congress.
And so that's why I think it's
particularly appropriate that we are
in this room today for
this very special program.
This room in this building when
it was opened in 189-- 1897.
Served as the reading room for
the House of Representatives.
And today it's known as the
member's room and reserved
for the use of members of Congress.
And so with that, we're
very delighted to have
with us 2 members of Congress today.
In this room, to tell us a
little bit about their careers.
Chairman Candice Miller
from Michigan
and Representative Janice
Hahn from California.
They're here to kick
off our celebration
of women's history month.
Both Chairman Miller
and Representative Hahn have
had distinguished careers
in public service.
And so we're very much looking
forward to hearing from them.
Their thoughts about
their time in Congress.
And in particular the
role that gender plays
in today's political
leadership and landscape.
Our discussion will
be lead and moderated
by my colleague, Doctor
Colleen Shogan.
Who is the director
of our national--
excuse me, Deputy Director
of National
and International Outreach
here at the library.
Today's topic though, of course, is
of particular interest to Colleen.
Because as the former
Deputy Director
of the Congressional
Research Service.
She had authored at her time in CRS,
an often cited CRS report
on Women in Congress.
So-- please join me in welcoming
all of our distinguished members
of Congress and Doctor
Colleen Shogan.
Thank you [applause].
>> Colleen Shogan: Welcome
to the Library of Congress
and this beautiful
room this morning.
As at the end of our
program we hope to have time
for questions from the audience.
But I'm going to kick
it off this morning.
You both have had very long and
distinguished careers in politics.
But you both had different
entries into public service.
So can you tell us about how
and why you became interested
in government service
in the first place?
Chairman Miller.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Well
for me, I live in-- Chairman--
or David Mao was just talking
about the tenth district.
You know, in Michigan we have a map
of the state on the end of our arm.
So I-- live in this area here.
This is my-- district.
And-- on the Great Lakes and my
family was in the marina business.
So I actually sold
boats for a living.
And-- I raised sailboats and
that was sort of our-- hobby.
And our way we made our
living, our social-- everything.
Everything was boating oriented.
And when I was in my mid-20's,
the local township
decided they were going
to pass an ordinance
to tax all the marinas.
Because about 40% of
the commercial tax base
in our area is all marina oriented.
And in a family business
you do everything.
I mean everything, right?
From doing the books to
selling boats to whatever.
And I remember telling--
I was doing the books.
And I remember telling my dad.
I said, "We just can't afford this!"
They were going to tax so
much for wet storage in the--
in the water storage,
so much for dry storage.
And I said-- you-- I don't know.
I probably said, "Taxation
without representation"
or I don't know what
I was saying you know.
And my dad sort of
padded me on the head.
He says, "Oh no-- " Because
he used to call me Candy--
don't tell anyone that
but-- [laughter].
Yes, yes but then when
I ran for office I said,
"I have to be Candice now."
But anyway, he said,
"Well Candy, you know,
you can't-- fight city hall so-- "
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: "You
know, this is what we got to do."
I said, "Well then-- " I
just couldn't believe it.
So I went around to
all these marinas
and got these petitions signed.
And long story, short went
into the township off--
the township board meeting.
And you know, gosh I was so riled up
but I was sitting way
in the back of the room.
And I'll never forget when
they got to our-- agenda item.
All these guys that own the
marina said, "Okay, you know,
get up there and tell them."
And I went [Gasp].
I still can remember
my heart pounding.
Because I had never spoken
publicly or anything.
Never thought about politics.
And sometimes for me,
I think anxiety almost
manifests itself in anger.
So I was like, "Listen!
[laughs] can't do this".
And we were successful.
I thought, "Oh my gosh!
If you're really obnoxious you
could become a politician!"
You know [laughs] so
then I'm looking
at all these other
people on the board.
And it thought, "Hey
I could do that."
So then I ran, I was too young
to know I wouldn't win but I won.
And that's-- here I am.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Representative Hahn.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Well I had
a-- sort of a different entry.
You know your family was
in boating and marinas.
My family actually was in politics.
So it's really everything
we talked about.
We talked about politics
at the dinner table.
My dad was a 46 year elected
official in Los Angeles County.
My brother was the City
Controller, the City attorney
and then the Mayor of Los Angeles.
So our family-- it was
really our family business.
I didn't quite embrace it.
In the beginning, I actually
have my teaching credential--
my secondary teaching credential.
I actually taught junior
high and high school.
I went into small business.
I worked for an investor-owned
utility.
I worked for a trash company.
I sort of did all these other things
and then I think it just hit me.
The DNA kicked in.
It's one of those moments
where you're sort of,
you know, lying in bed at night.
And you're like, "You know what?
What am I supposed
to be doing here?"
And it was very clear to me that
the best way I could affect change
in my community and my neighborhood
was to run for-- public office.
I lost my first race.
I was like the first
member of my family
to ever lose in a race [laughter].
It was very humiliating
and embarrassing.
But you know what?
I knew that that's
what I wanted to do.
And then 8 years later I
ran again and was elected
to the Los Angeles City Council.
You know I waited so
long to actually--
it wasn't until I was 49 or 50
when I actually had my
first elected office.
And so, sort of funny that
finally when I got elected in 2001.
It was the same night that
my brother was elected Mayor.
So [laughter] I joke
that even my mother went
to his victory party, you know?
[laughter].
That's how I got into politics.
>> Colleen Shogan: At a certain
point one day you both decided
to run for Congress.
Can you tell us about that moment
when you decided to
run for Congress?
And what influenced your decision?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Well
I had 2 different moments
because I ran in 80-- gosh.
Isn't it terrible?
I can't remember if
it was '84 or '86?
I ran for Congress.
I was 30 at the time,
trying to remember.
So-- anyway and lost and lost.
And so-- I was-- I was you know.
I had been the Township supervisor.
I started my career, political
career as a Township trustee
for a short period of time.
Then I became a supervisor
in Michigan.
That's really like
being a Mayor right?
And we had one of the larger
townships in the state.
And so then I ran for
congress and-- lost.
And-- that's the only
race that I've lost.
But I recognize all the
reasons why I did loose.
But anyway, then I-- was
still the Township Supervisor.
I think I ran for one
more term after that.
Then I was the County
Treasurer in Macomb County
which you sometimes hear this term.
The Reagan's-- Reagan democrats.
That term had its genesis really
in the political nomenclature
in our County.
And you-- you'll probably hear
tomorrow night at the Fox Theatre
with the Republican
Presidential debate.
And-- when the dems
are in Flint on Sunday.
They'll be talking a little
bit about Macomb County.
Because it's about whether we
don't even know if we're democrats,
republicans, what we
are half the time.
We're like we're in a
Petri dish, you know?
They're like, "What are they going
to-- what are they going to do?"
But anyway, then I was the sec--
Michigan secretary
of state for 8 years.
And we have term limits in Michigan.
And as secretary that's one of the 4
constitutional offices in the state.
And so you know in term
limits it's a-- [Noise].
>> Colleen Shogan: That's the
ghost of the members room.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Oh!
[Laughs].
>> Colleen Shogan:
Don't worry about it.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
What's its name?
[Laughter] Woo-hoo!
Anyway, he does not
like term limits.
That's what I was talking about.
>> Colleen Shogan: That's right.
Right?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Anyway,
the-- so term limits it's you know,
"nice job but drive thru."
And so then I was trying to
decide, "Should I go back
into the private sector
selling boats?
Or doing something else?"
And-- then I decided
to run for Congress.
And so I came here the ra--
the race was in '02 [noise].
I got-- I have the
microphone Mr. Ghost.
>> Colleen Shogan: Right?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: I came
here in '02, started in '03.
And I have been here
now-- so this is 14 years.
And of course both
of us are deciding
to do something else
with our-- lives, right?
We both have another dance
in us, whatever that is.
So-- I'm just finishing
my seventh term.
Which has been the most incredible
experience I have ever had.
>> Colleen Shogan: Yeah, absolutely.
Representative Hahn.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: So that after I
lost the city council race in 1993.
Until I won the city
council in 2001.
Those you know 8 years,
I was really focused on--
I was a single mother at the time.
I was raising my 3 kids.
I was an investment banker.
This was when I was
really just focusing
on you know jobs and making money.
And in 1998, my member of
Congress, Jane Harman decided to run
for Governor of California.
So she stepped down and now that
I'm back here I understand how the
individual caucuses work.
And if some member wants
to give up their seat.
Man, it is a full court press
to find a good candidate to run
in their race and replace them.
So they came after me [noise].
It's the ghost of former
members [laughter] which is
where we're going to be very soon.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
We'll be back here haunting.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Yes, right.
So I got phone calls
from Steny Hoyer.
I never heard of Steny Hoyer.
I got-- actually got a call
from President Clinton.
Vice President Gore, they were
all trying to recruit someone
who had a similar profile
to Jane Harman, right?
A woman, same initials-- [laughter].
I-- in my heart of
hearts wasn't feeling it.
But I-- it got to the sort of
answering the call to my country.
You know, they're really asking me
to do this so I did it and lost.
It was apparently one of the closest
congressional races in the country.
Lost by just 2 percentage points
which is not very much
in a congressional race.
But you know what?
It's like the best thing
that ever happened to me.
I do believe that things
happen for a reason.
You don't always know it
when you're going through it.
And it's never fun to lose.
But as a result of me not
going to Congress in 1998.
That's when then I was elected
to the local city council.
And I got to cut my own political
teeth at the local level.
And that was important
for me as a woman.
I sort of grew up being the
daughter of-- and the sister of--
these 2 very successful make
politicians in Los Angeles County.
So it was really important for
me to cut my own political teeth
in the Los Angeles City Council.
So for 10 years I served there.
We also have term limits
in City Council.
So I was bumping up to my 12 years.
And once again, Jane Harman.
She went back and after I lost.
She was like, "Well clearly
Janice couldn't do that.
I have to come back
and win that seat."
And then she called me again
one early February morning.
And said, "I'm resigning
from Congress this week.
And I think you ought
to run for my seat."
So thought about it.
You know, kind of called
my political consultants
and we had our website
up by noon [laughter].
And this time it felt right.
It felt good.
And so I was elected in 2011
in the special election.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Throughout your careers,
you both witnessed a transformation
of women's political participation
in particularly electoral politics.
Can you tell us how has
that transformation?
How has that evolution
affected you personally?
From the time in which you
began your public service.
When you began your career.
How it was then to what you
see now as more women start
to participate in electoral
politics?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Me first?
>> Colleen Shogan: Sure go ahead.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: You
know I would just say this.
I think-- when I was-- when I
was first running for office.
I was also a single
mother at that time.
And I couldn't afford a babysitter.
And I dragged my little
daughter around.
Whose now in her 40's and the mother
of the world's 2 most
beautiful grandchildren.
But I--
>> Rep. Janice Hahn:
Wait until you see mine.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Know
you would argue with that one.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I know.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
But I dragged her
around the neighborhoods
going door to door in a wagon.
I tried to make a game
out of it, you know?
Because I just couldn't
afford a sitter.
And there we-- and people
were looking at me going.
First I was young, right?
I mean in my 20's but
then more than that.
They'd say, "I mean
you're like a woman."
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Seriously, you know?
"What are you doing?
And now you want to be
you know the supervisor?
Oh yeah right."
And so I was the first female
supervisor in my community.
And then I was the
first County Treasurer
in my County-- first woman.
Then I was the first woman
secretary of state in Michigan.
>> Colleen Shogan:
There's a theme here.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: You know?
Well-- but you know all of these
things and sometimes you know I'm--
as you might know I'm
the only woman chairman.
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: In
the House of Representatives.
>> Colleen Shogan: Yes.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: But you
know what the truth is really.
I mean I got the whole woman thing.
But I've never really, you know.
"Oh you're the woman
member of Congress."
I'm like, "Well I don't know.
I'm like the-- I'm the
member of Congress.
And in issues that they
talk about for women."
I think all issues are
women's issues, you know.
Sometimes they'll say,
"Oh well okay.
Here's the health issues.
Now, you know, this is
the woman's issue" Right?
You and I sit on transportation.
What's more important
to women than--
>>Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Transportation.
Really, right?
Whatever they're-- whether they're
flying or being in their car or--
>> Colleen Shogan: Exactly.
>>Rep. Candice Miller: Safety in
rail or-- you know everything.
And I'm the Vice Chair of the
Homeland Security Committee.
What's more important
to women than security?
Security of the homeland, etcetera.
But it has changed over the years.
Because where it was a negative.
Then at one point it seemed they
said, "Well people would now vote
for you because you are a woman."
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
And really I think
if it can just be because
of the merits.
That's really where we all need to
go but I've also always said this.
I think we need more women
to be involved in politics.
Whether you're democrat, republican.
Whether you're running for
Congress or you're running
for your local school board.
We need to have more women.
We need to have their view.
And I think it is for all of
us that do hold public office
to conduct ourselves well.
As well as we can because
you know what?
It's very generational.
And the next generation of
women need to be thinking
about how they can succeed in
politics and have an impact.
Because it is-- we do
have a different mindset.
We are all biological
beings after all, right?
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I-- am
pleased with the evolution
of seeing more women
participating in politics.
Particularly running for
office and being elected.
I think the evolution
has helped, you know,
those of us who are
women and in office.
And those who may be
thinking about it.
When I first ran for office,
there were very few women
who were my role models.
Who had been elected to office.
Very few. In fact, my staff
always cracks up at this story.
Wasn't really funny at the time.
But when I went through my
divorce, my ex actually filed
for full custody of the children.
Because he said if I
was elected to office,
it would make me an unfit mother.
>> Colleen Shogan: Wow.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: So yeah I know.
You kind of laugh about that now.
But you know there was this
feeling even you know in the'90's.
It's hard to believe.
That there was still this
feeling that that's not
where a woman really belonged
was in the political arena.
So I think it helps
that more women are--
running for office
and being elected.
And as Candice said, you
know, we need more women.
In congress, we're
only 20% of women.
Even though we're 50%
of the population.
We're only 20% of the
members of Congress.
You know, I think one of the
statistics that was amazing
to me when I got elected.
I, you know, all the
years in Congress.
There'd only been 212, you
know, women elected, you know.
And now of course--
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
It's hard, yeah.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: We're you
know kind of upping that number.
But I do believe that
women come to the table
with a different set of experiences.
I do believe we have sort
of a different perspective.
And I like the way we govern.
I think we govern more--
with more collaboration.
I think we like to find
common ground and consensus.
And solve problems so I
like the way women govern.
But I'm wondering if we're almost--
it's now, it's going the other way.
Because when I'm looking to
recruit for political offices.
I'm looking for good women.
I have a hard time now.
There are women who now,
you know, have careers.
And actually watching politics,
particularly during
this presidential year.
There's a lot of women
that are like,
"I don't really want to do that.
You know, that's really nasty.
That's-- do we really want to
put our families through that?
Do I really want to, you know, have
everything in my life scrutinized?"
So I think it's-- I'm finding less
women now who are wanting to run.
They'll be involved, will
help you on your campaign.
More and more women are
understanding what it means
to make a contribution to a-- to
a woman who's running for office.
But I'm thinking women
are sort of now, you know,
like not as excited
about being in office.
Because of what's happened
to our politics of civility.
Which sometimes you wonder
if that even exists anymore.
>> Colleen Shogan: I'm
going to ask you to both--
you got into this a little
bit Representative Hahn.
But I need to ask you both to engage
in the thought experiment with us.
As you said, 20% of members
of Congress are women
in the current Congress.
And I want to ask you, what
would the institution--
what would congress look like?
Or how would it operate differently
if 50% of its members were women?
Or even 51% of its
members were women?
How would the institution
operate differently if at all?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: I do
think it would be a bit different.
I do think-- I think most of us
would agree that women have a bit
of a different perspective
on how they approach things.
Whatever your political ideology
is, more of the cultural way
that you approach various things.
Where you are trying
to reach a consensus.
I think more often than just you
know, "Okay I don't agree with you.
I'm going to put on
the war paint here.
We're going, you know?
Let's just think about
how we might be able
to get through these things."
And now, I'm not talking
from an ideology standpoint.
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: But just
the approach to problem solving.
I think is a bit different.
And-- so I think in-- of all
the various issues in that.
If we just had more
voices for women.
I think-- I think that
would be an important thing.
But I will agree with you.
I think where you had an
easier time recruiting women.
Because I've done candidate
recruitment for my party.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: I
know you have for you party.
It does seem it's a-- it's a--
it's a little more difficult now.
And-- which is not good.
>> Colleen Shogan: No.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: It's
not good for the country.
Although with all of our
problems, only having 20%
in the Congress, I'll tell you.
You know one of the opportunities
I've had in this job is travel.
You know, you have as well.
But I can remember going to
Afghanistan and we landed in Kabul.
Which you know is sort
of like a saucer, right?
With all the mountain
range around it
and all the snow melt
was coming down.
And these children
are standing there
in the snow melt with no shoes.
And you know, you could
just see they were--
they're not going to
make it, you know?
And they don't have
any facilities there
for their women or their children.
These-- some of these societies,
I'm sorry, they just don't care
about their women so much.
And then traveling to
we went to see Karzai.
And traveling to the
Presidential Palace,
it was like teeming with people.
And I kept saying, "Well
where are the women?
Where are they?"
It's so bizarre.
So for all of our problems,
you know,
I tell young women
that all the time.
Just go do it man.
Because you-- have
opportunities here.
You might have challenges
but you don't have the
challenges your sisters
in many other countries have.
So take advantage.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Anyhow I
was thinking about this question.
What would run differently
if there were more women?
I don't know.
Maybe we would carpet all
the marble halls [laughter].
Because there's so
hard on our high heels.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: This
is a sensible shoe caucus.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I know.
I got shin splints my first
year in Congress [laughter].
But I-- think beyond that you know.
I find that my friendships
with the few women
in Congress are really special.
And they, you know, it allows me
even across the aisle to find,
you know, areas of common ground.
Areas of consensus
and there is not the--
you know, the hostility that exists.
I think sometimes between the men.
I mean we don't have testosterone.
That changes a lot
of things [laughter].
Changes a lot of the--
you know, the atmosphere.
It changes a lot of where
you go on a conversation.
It changes a lot of you know
the agenda of-- the house.
So I would love to see
more women in Congress.
I think it would you know
really be an opportunity
to show you know the world.
That you know we can be
from different parties
and yet we can get along.
And we can find common ground.
And I think it would-- I think it
would help if we had more women.
I'd love to see more women
you know chairs of committees.
I just think, you know--
>> Rep. Candice Miller: You
don't think one is enough?
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I know right?
I know. You know--
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
One is not enough?
We could have a few more [laughs].
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I, you know,
I think we run things differently.
Again, I think we just bring
different perspectives to the table.
>> Colleen Shogan: Unfortunately
you're both retiring from Congress
and leaving us later this year.
I wonder if you could share with
us some of your future plans.
And what you're most
looking forward to doing?
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Well you know first of all.
When I first came here I
never thought I would stay
as long as I have stayed.
>> Colleen Shogan: Huh?
>>Rep. Candice Miller: And I
know a lot of people say that.
And I think also people
say, "You sort of know
when is your time to go" right?
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
When you're done.
And that was really true for me.
But I thought I would be
here 6 years, 8 years maybe.
You know I'm going
to tell you though.
It's like any other job I guess.
Maybe more so than a lot of jobs.
It's sort of insidious, you know.
Pretty soon you think,
"Well now I'm the chairman.
I can't leave now or I got
this issue I'm working on.
I can't leave now".
Well pretty soon you're
never going to leave.
And then they're going to
maybe take you out on a gurney.
And I don't want go
that way [laughter].
And I truly love Michigan.
I'm a Michigan girl.
And I want to go home to Michigan.
So I'm looking forward
to whatever it is next.
I'm not quite sure what?
But I'll tell you the
experiences that I have had here.
There's absolutely no second.
And so I-- you know,
I don't know how--
I hope to be of value at somewhere.
I might run for office
again, you know.
I might not.
I might go back into
the private sector.
But I also say this.
This is just my personal feeling.
I-- really do think the
founding fathers always thought
that for Congress.
Particularly in the House, that
you would come from various sectors
of your-- of the country.
And do your thing for
some period of time.
And then you would go back.
Not just be here forever.
And really if you want
to know the truth
and this is not a partisan thing.
Sometimes I think part of the
gridlock problems we have is
because some people don't leave.
They never go.
So even when you have a
Presidential election.
Now you have a new President but
then you still have-- then they go.
"Oh okay well here's this new guy.
But here they-- they've
all been here."
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
So I don't know.
That's-- I'm not-- and I'm not
saying about any particular person.
I'm just saying in my observation
I do think it's the people's house.
You know, I don't-- I don't know
what the right amount of time is.
But I don't think it
should be forever.
>> Colleen Shogan: Okay.
Representative Hahn.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: So I'm--
well have been here
only 5 years this July.
And when I end my term
at the end of the year,
it'll be like 5 and a half years.
But I am going home to Los Angeles.
And I'm currently-- I'm
going to be on the ballot
for County Supervisor
in Los Angeles.
So it's the same job my
dad did for 40 years.
I sort of grew up in the
County of Los Angeles.
And kind of really understood what
a supervisor was in LA County.
So I'm really looking
forward to going home.
I think-- you know, when I said I
cut my teeth on the City Council.
I-- really believe for
me, it's a better fit
for me, is local government.
I like the idea of sort of
where the rubber meets the road.
I like you know seeing my
constituents in the grocery store.
And you know they want their tree
trimmed or their pothole filled
or their sidewalk-- I like that.
I like actually seeing
the fruits of my labor.
Seeing a problem and solving it.
There's only 5 members of the
County Board of Supervisors.
And actually with my candidacy,
there is a historic opportunity
for 3 females to be on the LA
County Board of Supervisors.
For the first time in the
history of the County.
My dad was there.
It was you know the
old boy's network.
It was-- they called
them the 5 kings.
And-- but now with diversity and
more women I look forward to working
with 2 other women, you
know, out of-- out of 5.
To really, you know, talk about
you know issues that matter
to most people in the
county of Los Angeles.
So I'm-- I know where I'm going.
And I feel good but I-- will
look back on my time here.
As of course being such
an amazing experience.
Really such an opportunity to
serve as a member of Congress.
It's really been a very
special and satisfying to me.
But frustrating also
just in the gridlock.
You know I think I landed in one of
the more partisan political divides
that Congress has been
in a long time.
And I don't enjoy it.
I decided I don't enjoy
partisan politics.
Los Angeles County
Supervisor is non-partisan.
You just you know you look at
a problem and you solve it.
And you don't really have
to worry about one side
or the other making
political points.
And I think it'll be
a better fit for me.
And if I never get on a
plane again [laughter].
It will be too soon.
I have a 3,000 mile
commute every week.
I fly here on Mondays and fly
home on Thursdays every week.
And that has taken a toll.
>> Colleen Shogan: Oh yeah, yeah.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: So-- which is
why I was trying to pass legislation
about seat sizes [laughter].
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Yeah [laughs].
Why? We have 7 inches.
How much room do you need there?
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: After 6 hours
like, "Oh, it's so uncomfortable."
>> Colleen Shogan: Chairman Miller.
We have one last question for you.
It's sort of a humorous question.
I wonder if you could tell
us about your nickname?
And-- "old goat" and how
you got that nickname?
And why you are so
proud to have earned it?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Well,
jeez the old goat [laughter].
I told you I used to race sailboats.
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
And my whole family does.
But anyway, there is
sort of a Marquis race--
Freshwater Sailboat Race
in the world really.
Is on Lake Huron.
It's Port Huron to Mackinac.
Any of you heard of Mackinac Island.
>>Colleen Shogan: Yeah.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: So there's
this Port Huron to Mackinac race.
There's another one in
Chicago to Mackinac.
And-- first of all I
will tell you I was
in the first all-female crew
in the Chicago Mackinac.
And also the first all-female crew
in the Port Huron to Mackinac.
>> Colleen Shogan: Yay.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Many years ago.
I was 15 at the time.
>> Colleen Shogan: Very cool.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
"Oh my gosh, I can't even--
" I'm really dating myself.
But anyway, in Port Huron race after
you compete in 25 of these races.
They induct you into what they
call the Old Goat Society.
And I've done 29 of them.
So I am actually an old nanny goat.
>> Colleen Shogan: Oh!
>> Rep. Candice Miller: And--
>>Colleen Shogan: You're a goat.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
And I know this to be true.
I am the only old nanny goat
in the United States count.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Wow, there you go.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: [Laughs].
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: And you
can keep that title [laughter].
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
I earned it baby.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Right.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: [Laughs].
>> Colleen Shogan: So now we--
can like open it up to
questions from the audience.
If you do chose to ask a
question, please just be aware
that we are videotaping
this conversation.
So if anybody would like to ask a
question, please raise your hand.
Take questions at this time.
Robert.
>> Robert: I'd like to ask the
members if there were any books
that they've read along the way
that influenced their
thinking in Congress?
Or influenced their
thinking about leadership?
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
I'm not going to say
"The Art of the Deal" [laughter].
I don't know if there was
ever any one particular book
that has influenced me.
But-- I don't know if I
can answer that question.
Really I can't think
of one particular book
that really influenced me.
People more I think.
Individual experiences and that.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: So I had
fund reading "Game Change".
And I had fun reading "This Town."
Those were really a little
bit behind the scenes
political campaigns.
And kind of what goes into
that and how that translates
to actually being in governance.
I found those books--
and I enjoy the books
that were having our
congressional dialogue.
>>Rep. Candice Miller: Yes.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn:
"Lyndon Johnson",
"Reagan" and "Kennedy" coming up.
I've really enjoyed those to kind
of really take us back
to the way it was.
It was like, again though, in those
books it's like where are the women?
But--
>> Colleen Shogan: Yup, I did.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Still
those really have in--
have-- reminded me where I am.
And reminded me who's
gone before me.
And reminded me of the, you
know, sometimes incredible fights
that went on to achieve certain
policies for the American people.
So I've really enjoyed those.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: That's true.
The history of this place--
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I know.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Is sometimes, you know,
honestly I'm sure we
all have this feeling.
You know sometimes in the winter
when-- it's days are short.
And you're walking across
Independence Avenue over here
to go vote at the Capitol.
And there's the Capitol all lit
up and you know you're walking--
you're looking at the
lady Freedom Statue.
Thinking, "Man you go girl".
That's really something, right?
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I know, right?
>>Rep. Candice Miller: And you
just pinch yourself thinking.
"How, what-- am I even--
how did I even get here?"
With all the history
that has happened here.
And really in this Capitol
it's quite something.
>> Colleen Shogan: Other questions?
Anybody else in the audience?
>> You spoke to the importance of
the diversity in gender in Congress.
And I'd like to hear both of you
speak to how you think we are doing
in terms of diversity and
ethnicity in Congress?
And what are our losses
and gains related to that?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: We are
not doing particularly well.
I don't think.
Certainly on my side of the isle,
we need to do a much better job.
And don't think that
we're not all aware of it.
I will tell you though, I
think in politics generally.
I mentioned to you earlier
I mean I was the Secretary
of State of Michigan.
And when I first ran for that
job I was running against
and older African American
incumbent.
And the truth-- and here I was
running as the first female, right?
And really I will tell
you in all sincerity.
That race-- I don't
think anyone ever said.
"Oh well we need to vote for him
because he's an African American.
Or we need to vote for her
because she's the woman."
It really was about the issues.
And I have always thought about
that because at some point that's
where we need to be
as a country, right?
Whatever the-- whatever the-- issues
are, is always got to be paramount.
And you know this is the land
of opportunity and all men
and women are created equal.
So but we need to do
a much better job.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I will say
I'm proud of the Democratic caucus.
Actually has-- this is
I think our first time
when we've actually had a
majority of minority representation
in our Democratic caucus.
So we have more women,
more African Americans
and more Latinos and
Asian Americans.
Than I think ever before
in our caucus so--
but I-- do-- I agree you know.
It should be about the issues.
And I actually represent a
minority district right now.
I represent a district that's--
you know, 48% Latino,
28% African American.
So I represent a very you
know diverse district.
But I-- it's sort of
like women though.
I do believe people come to the
table with different experiences.
And I think for those, you
know, our diverse ethnicity.
Our African Americans, our Latinos,
our Asian Americans, our LGBT.
They come with a different
set of experiences
and a different perspective.
And they have seen life
differently and I think that makes
for a better congress
and a better America.
And you do the best you can
to represent the people
that have elected you.
But I do love the different
perspectives that come
from all over this country.
And people who have lived a
different life than I have.
And I think that makes
for better policy.
That makes for better judgement.
That makes for I think
a better understanding
of what the American
people are wanting from us.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Any other questions?
Oh. Oh David, oh okay, go ahead.
I didn't--
>> David Mao: Reflecting--
thank you very much
for your presentation today.
It was fascinating.
Reflecting on your careers though.
If you were speaking
to a young woman
who is starting out
in politics today.
Whether it be on the
local level, state level
or even a new member of Congress.
What one piece of advice
would you give them to think
about to guide them along their way?
>>Rep. Candice Miller: I would say
that they need to find the balance
between their professional
life and their family.
And that they can find that balance.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn:
How do you do that?
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Yeah [laughs].
Well they need to do it.
Otherwise and that's--
I think that's why women
don't want to do it, right?
And often times because not
only are they the caregivers
for their children.
They're usually the caregivers
if they have older parents.
They're all of these things, right?
And then women also have a--
just for whatever reason.
Whether it's because of
the way we were all raised.
We have an aversion to asking
somebody for money for us, right?
>> Colleen Shogan: Yeah.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: You don't
mind asking people for money
for the local schoolboard.
Or the you know the
hospital board or something.
But for yourself, sometimes
you think it's sort of--
you just have to get over
all of these things you know.
So I just tell women that you
know I think they need to think
about finding that balance.
And that it's important that
we do have more women involved.
And I actually go-- I try to speak
to local high school
kids when I can.
I have throughout my entire career.
Because really if a woman
is going to be thinking
about a political career.
You need to at least plant
the seed at that time
that politics can be an honorable
profession for them to think about.
And that they should
consider such a thing.
And that they might want to go out
and think about getting involved
in a campaign or-- do something
where they hopefully you know.
If there's 40 in a room
then hopefully there's 1
that will catch the
political bug and think
about running for something.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn: I know.
And you know actually
you kind of touched
on it earlier in something you said.
But it is true still to this
day women do have an advantage
because of the-- trust issue.
The-- if there's just a woman
and a man on the ballot.
Your pollsters will tell you.
Women get a couple of points just
because we're more believable.
And when the negative
campaigning comes against us.
Less and less voters believe that.
They don't believe that about us.
That all the things our
opponents are saying.
So there is still an advantage.
If I was giving a woman
any kind of advice,
particularly if she
was coming to Congress.
I would say have 2 complete
sets of wardrobes [laughter].
Have everything you need at home
and everything you need here.
Don't be trying to remember
what shoes go with what outfit.
Because you know they're going to
be in the other location [laughter].
But I think seriously I would just
remind women to know their value.
Know their value.
I know Mika Brzezinski does this--
thing every year about
women knowing their value.
And then mostly women still have
a hard time knowing their value
and knowing why they're important.
And knowing the role that they play.
Because when you're--
particularly in Congress when you're
in the minority you know.
It's you know, it takes
a little more courage.
It takes a little more
bravery to speak up.
To think that your idea is
really worth you know pushing.
That your legislation makes sense.
That you know you really
are doing a good thing.
Because I still think women tend
to sometimes not value themselves
in the way that our
male counterparts do.
So it does take a little bravery I
think to be back here as a woman.
And to speak up and to not be
you know in any way intimidated.
About the questions that
you ask in committees,
legislation that you're
pushing forward.
Because it can be an intimidating
place I think sometimes.
>> Colleen Shogan:
Any further questions?
Yes?
>> Hi, you both mentioned
that some of the friendships
that you have made in Congress
were particularly important to you.
And I was wondering when
you were first starting out.
If there was a particular person
or a particular moment
you can remember?
Where another woman in
Congress really helped you out
or showed you the ropes
or something like that?
>>Rep. Candice Miller: [Laughs]
I don't know if there was one--
again one particular moment.
But I've had, you know, some good
friendships that have been there.
Some of the women that I came into
to Congress with are no longer here.
You know even though people think
that we all stay here forever.
Actually the truth is there's a lot
more turnover than you'd imagine.
And some of the women that I've--
that I was good friends
with have left on their own.
Some got beat.
Different things.
But I do think women
have a tendency to again,
whether we're Democrats
or Republicans.
To talk about our family,
the challenges
that we're facing at home.
I mean you know we
have this woman's room,
the Lindy Boggs room
off the-- which really.
It was Boehner who finally put
in the ladies room off
the-- off the house floor.
Not that we need one, okay?
[laughter] Because--
you're sort of saying,
"Well where's the bathrooms
over here?
Well, the men's room is over here.
I mean what-- is it
you're looking for?
Okay." But anyway [laughs]
but the Lindy Boggs room is
sort of where the women go.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: The only room
in the Capitol named for a woman.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Yeah, yeah.
And-- gosh sometimes when we're
here at night voting late.
I can remember one member who was on
the phone obviously very distraught.
And was saying you know-- I don't
know whatever was happening.
And she said, "You
know I'm so far away."
And just the anguish
and you know women--
you know you've got
children, grandchildren.
You know your spouses,
your family, whatever.
It is-- and so I think women have
a tendency that-- recognizing that.
And want another in
challenges that-- and I'm not--
believe I'm not whining about it.
I'm just saying that that
you know we do have that.
So it's just a different situation.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn: So when I came
here I really hardly knew anybody.
I had really not spent that much
time coming to Washington DC even
for lobbying trips
with my City Council.
I really did not spend
that much time here.
So I really didn't know anybody.
Well one of the first people
I wanted to say hello to
and introduce myself was
to my Republican colleague,
Ted Poe from Texas.
Because Ted and I are
the only 2 alumnae
from Abilene Christian
University in Abilene, Texas,
that are members of Congress.
So I you know went
and said hello to Ted.
And we've-- we struck up,
obviously a conversation based
on our shared history
with the university.
And then I asked him to co-chair--
one of the first things that I
did was created a port caucus.
You know based on our
nation's sea ports.
It really had never
been done before.
And I represented the ports
of Los Angeles and Long Beach.
And he of course represented a bunch
of ports in Texas, Houston area.
And I said, "Would you co-chair
this port caucus with me?"
We now have about 100
members of Congress,
both Republicans and Democrats.
Some of them who don't
even have a port.
But they're happy to be in a--
you know, sort of a
collegial bipartisan effort.
And it was a big thrill 2 years ago
when the American Authority of--
Association of Port
Authorities named Ted
and I as joint port
people of the year.
So that was really special.
You know, speaking of
the Lindy Boogs room.
So every Wednesday morning at
8:00 AM there is a group of women.
Diane Black, Marsha Blackburn,
Virginia Fox, Christy [inaudible]
and Susan-- Senator
Susan Collins and myself.
And sometimes my colleague
from California Lois Capps
and we actually have a bible
study in the Lindy Boggs room.
And it's you know sometimes
we-- pray and read the bible.
But mostly it's talking--
>>Rep. Candice Miller: Yeah.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn:
About our experience here.
And having someone who understands
what we're going through.
And we can talk to them when
you can't really-- you know.
Because your constituents don't
really want to hear you whine
about your experience, right?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Right.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: And-- it's
not appropriate to complain
about your experience
with your constituents.
But it sure is nice to
have some girlfriends even
from across the aisle.
That you know we share the same
rhythm, the experience, the timing.
We have the same votes.
You know we have the
same schedules basically.
And it helps to talk to them.
So that's been a real
special time for me.
Now when I tell my Democratic
colleagues who is in this.
You know, they can't believe
that I'm you know hanging
out with the likes of those women.
But I [laughter] really--
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Well wait
until they find out
what you did today.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I
know right [laughter] I got
to hang out with you.
But I find it--
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
Don't tell anyone.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: I know.
I find it's something
that I do for myself.
And it helps me get
through my week here.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
You know what?
I just have to make a comment, an
observation talking about friends
on the other side of the aisle.
Because I see my good friend
Debbie Dingell from Michigan,
who is a freshman member.
But she and I go way back.
She-- grew up actually
in my district.
Now she lives further down--
stream, down the Detroit River.
But her and I this week in honor
of Michigan's History month.
Are going to bring in
Rosie the Riveters.
And you know and South
East Michigan was known
as the arsenal of democracy.
And so many of-- during World War II
and these women literally
built the armaments
that led the entire world to peace.
Remarkable women and you hear
about all these honor flight
coming for World War II.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Yeah.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
And she and I said,
"We need to bring these Rosie's".
And so the Library of
Congress has been very,
very helpful in putting together--
well we have some great posters.
That we got out of the archives here
that we're going to
give the Rosie's.
And you know they're in their late
80's, 90's remarkable stories.
But again something that you can do
across the aisle to make an impact
in recognition of unbelievable
ta-- patriots certainly.
>> Colleen Shogan: I
see another question.
>> Okay I don't really
have a question.
But I just want to tell you both
how much I admire all the women
in Congress and in the Senate.
I can say just listening
to you today.
You both have children.
You both have grandchildren.
And I'm the wife of Rick Allen,
George XII so I can tell you now.
I like my role as spouse.
I don't want to be you.
But I [laughter] and I say it a lot.
I don't know how you deal with--
I have -- I guilt it on myself.
But I heap that guilt here
with children back home.
And a mother, 94 year old mother
and I don't even have to be here.
You know I can go home
when I need to.
But I just admire you all so much.
I think it's-- incredible and you
both seem to have it-- have it down.
So whatever you're doing, I want you
to tell me later how
you do it [laughter].
Maybe it's because I have
to keep up with my husband
up here, you think that's it?
That's the hard part?
>>Rep. Candice Miller:
He's a very busy guy.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn: And
you know that's nice
that you're here too with him.
It's nice to have your
spouse or your family here.
I think one of the things that is
particularly difficult for a lot
of members of congress is
when after a really long day.
You go home and you shut
the door to your apartment.
And you are alone.
You are not with your family.
They are somewhere else.
And see those are the times
that you know your heart kind
of hurts a little bit.
That you're not surrounded by hearth
and home and a loving family member.
So we-- it's nice that you--
I put both my spouse pen's in my
hope chest at home [laughter].
>> Colleen Shogan: We have
time for one more question.
>> About staff, it
feels that there are--
I don't know the numbers but
anecdotally there a lot of women now
who seem to be in senior staff
positions in the Congress.
And I wonder if you could talk a bit
about what impact you
see that having?
And generally about--
women in staff positions?
>> Rep. Candice Miller: You know
I don't really know what the
percentage is of women staff.
But there certainly is a lot-- I'm
sure it's a much higher percentage
of staff than it is actual members.
I mean my Chief of Staff is a woman.
My district director is a woman.
>> Rep. Janice Hahn: Mine too.
>> Rep. Candice Miller:
But you know,
I have a mix gender
wise in both offices.
So-- I mean I've always had--
again, I mean I really do look
at the qualifications
of the individuals.
Because guess what?
If they're not doing a good job.
You know, you're probably going
to be out of your own job.
And so-- but there are certainly
many, many more women now I think
in particular senior levels.
Chiefs of-- on the
committees, staff directors,
all of those kinds of things.
And that's a very important
part of it.
I mean staff is the
most critical component
for any member of congress.
>>Rep. Janice Hahn: Yeah so
my Chief of Staff is a woman.
My scheduler is a woman.
My communications director
is a woman.
My district director is a woman.
Actually at one point
I was very happy
because back here in
DC we were all women.
We finally had an interloper a
guy that we-- [laughter] hired.
And he's there.
But I do think there's more
equality and opportunities
at the staff level on
the hill is my sense.
That there really they're
all equals.
And some of them have some
incredible institutional memory.
My chief of staff worked for Barbara
Boxer, worked for Jane Harman,
did a lot of work in transportation.
So she's a real source of
information and knowledge for me.
Particularly coming from you know
Los Angeles and not really being
in Washington DC politics.
So there is a-- I think there's
more equality and more opportunities
at the staff level for women.
>> Colleen Shogan: Well this has
been a tremendous conversation.
And would everybody please join me
in thanking Chairman Miller
and Representative Hahn.
>> Rep. Candice Miller: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.